so then when you're in this industry and
then when did you get out
2009 so we were in and out the original
years yeah three years yeah I thought I
was I would've thought it was gonna be a
lifer oh really
yeah but what was the reason I mean just
you're just done so so many things were
playing out at the same time but the
first and foremost reason was that I
felt like I had accomplished the things
that I set out to do and so the own the
next step naturally would be to create
my own company and start doing things my
own way but I the entire time I was in
porn I was doing other things I was
making music I was working on a
photography book I I'd shot two other
films like there's all these things
happening in my life and then I actually
had started a company and it failed and
it was the first I would say the first
major failure of my life was it a porn
yeah well how did it why did it fail and
so I'd spent about I don't know six
months something like that but let's say
a whole year because leading up to that
I was actively trying to put it together
and then from the time I actually did
and it all came crashing down I had to
make a decision and I was sleeping three
hours a night because I was working my
ass off yeah so for a good year that
that was my life and I had to make the
decision do I want to start over from
scratch and this is only a year after
the recession or within the same year
people weren't shooting as much as it
was and parodies became a big thing
they're so stupid they don't even put in
this same amount of like CGI Oh
that's what about yeah yeah you you
watch The Avengers 1 right this is
better yeah really cool I don't know
what that is if it's silkscreen or what
it is or a panel but like this is cooler
than a lot of the sets they would have
in those parodies yeah they would put
like in would spider-man would put they
put cotton you know me do you know a
Halloween or The Cosby ones or like this
oh yeah there's a cause there was a car
there was in fact my friend Thomas Ward
I have a friend because he's a porn star
oh okay like a cousin oh no Thomas
Warren own individual yeah is a stand-up
he used to be a stand-up I started with
them
and he looks kind of like Cosby right
he's a black eye and then he disappeared
from open mikes I know but you know what
I'm saying
yeah maybe a couple of meals with them
or whatever hotdog stand or whatever
yeah
Bill Cosby loved hot dogs yeah yeah you
know that right but anyway um so then
one night I was like I'll watch The
Cosby born he comes on and I go what the
[ __ ] and then I go that's Thomas Ward
and then he pulls his dick out it's like
[ __ ] this big and I remember trying in
the computer I was trying to shut it off
no no no and then I saw a lot of like
there was a phase where I liked you know
black and white porn interruptions ratio
no no I like old timey porn subtitle you
know I like black men and white women or
vice versa you know I mean and so he I
saw him in those two you know man very
talented he was a good comic but very
good for
star I have to say alright anyway did
you do a bi-racial ones as well yeah
Asian father cool no I don't only like
one or two Asians uh men
what do you mean in porn you only [ __ ]
two Asian yeah maybe